people do not have a right to a child
when we're talking about family when
we're talking about procreation the only
people who can be said to have any
rights whatsoever are the children a
child has a right to his natural mother
and father who are united together in
marriage in perpetuity and marriage is
an institution that unites husbands and
wives for the good of the spouses and
for the sake of the generation and
education of children gay men have no
right to purchase to rent the wombs of
poor women and to purchase the eggs of
poor women and to create children with
the express intent of of robbing those
children of their natural mothers that's
a really evil awful thing to do and I I
don't think that most of the people who
do this even really think about it